john cena making a young child's dream
come true so let me tell you what
happened here um
there's a young child who just escaped
from ukraine his name is misha
the former wwe star made a special trip
to meet 19 19 year old misha
and his mother leanna outside of
amsterdam earlier this month the family
had fled mariupol ukraine after the
russian invasion so here's why it's so
important misha has down syndrome and is
non-verbal and he didn't understand
why he had to leave his home so his mom
told him they were going to meet his
hero john cena well john cena got wind
of lyanna's story and decided to make
his dream come true listen to this
i think misha is a great example and
it's misha's mom they're two great
examples of how uh persistence can lead
to joy even through the toughest of
times
i already love john cena before this
moment because i love everything he's
ever done but
what a wonderful human being to take
time out he's shooting a movie in london
he flies over to amsterdam just to me
for a child for a person who's
non-verbal but knows who john cena is